Traduttore: Beatrice Vecchiato
Revisore: Federico MINELLE
Buongiorno, innanzitutto.
Bene, io voglio raccontarvi
due storie personali
che hanno cambiato la mia vita,
che hanno cambiato delle cose importanti.
La prima prende lo spunto
dal titolo che vedete:
"Ogni problema ha una soluzione".
Quindi vi parlerò di una storia
che riguarda questa coppia:
problema; soluzione.
Poi, quando il TED mi ha chiesto
di preparare questo racconto,
la mia mente ha cercato un secondo tema.
E improvvisamente mi è apparsa,
nello schermo della mente,
un'altra parola chiave,
che ritengo molto importante,
e che ha influenzato molto
la mia vita, ed è "ascoltare".
Queste slide rappresentano
questi due elementi;
ma la domanda che potreste
farmi voi è questa:
ma come sono connessi
problema e soluzione con l’ascolto?
C'è un intreccio? C'è una relazione?
Non la voglio svelare subito,
immagino che la capirete
durante il corso del mio racconto
ma poi cercheremo alla fine
di trovare una spiegazione.
Bene!
Palloncini.
L'esperienza che vi voglio raccontare
risale a circa una decina di anni fa:
ho frequentato un corso
per diventare coach.
Durante questa esperienza
il maestro, il supercoach,
ci ha fatto sedere a cerchio
e ci ha spiegato
che ci avrebbe raccontato,
anzi, fatto fare un'esperienza
per non pensare.
Una cosa incredibile!
Io vi racconterò questa esperienza:
e se volete, ciascuno di voi, adesso,
può farla, proprio qui in questo momento.
La prima cosa che il maestro ci ha chiesto
è di prendere una postura fisica,
quindi sentire la vostra schiena
diritta, se volete,
appoggiata bene contro lo schienale.
La seconda postura
sono i piedi e le gambe,
cioè cercate di avere
consapevolezza del vostro peso
appoggiando il peso delle vostre gambe
parallele sul terreno, sul pavimento,
e appoggiate la mano.
Dopodiché il maestro diceva:
"Per l'esperienza che voglio farvi fare,
chi vuole può chiudere gli occhi",
quindi anche voi potete
tenere aperti gli occhi, o chiuderli.
E che cosa ci suggerisce il maestro?
Quello che vedete -
immaginate che la vostra mente,
che è piena di rumore,
di pensieri che vi arrivano,
cercate di far entrare,
nello schermo della vostra mente,
dei palloncini.
I palloncini sono un'esperienza
che abbiamo da bambini,
quindi noi sappiamo che cos'è
un palloncino, col suo filo;
quindi cominciamo a proiettare,
nello schermo della nostra mente,
questi palloncini.
E il maestro cosa ci ha chiesto:
"Bene! Prendete il filo,
oppure la mano della mente,
e spostate questi palloncini
verso l'esterno".
Cioè fate in modo che questi palloncini,
che stanno entrando,
escano, escano, escano, escano...
Potete provare a farlo,
e vi accorgerete che i palloncini
possono davvero uscire.
Quando sono usciti tutti,
che cosa succede?
Lo schermo è quello che è:
sarà colorato, sarà grigio,
sarà azzurro, sarà rosso, dipende da voi.
C'è uno schermo pulito.
Questo è il momento in cui
non c'è più nessun pensiero
che vi faccia da rumore di fondo,
non c'è più nessun disturbo.
Ecco: questo è stato
un grandissimo insegnamento,
un grandissimo insegnamento
per predisporci a che cosa? All'ascolto!
Perché per ascoltare bisogna avere
la mente sgombra, pulita.
Ho visto che qualcuno di voi l'ha fatto:
quanti hanno visto i palloncini?
Potete alzare la mano?
Wow! Un terzo!
E quanti sono riusciti
a fare uscire i palloncini?
Quasi tutti: complimenti!
Veramente, vi applaudirei!
L'ascolto è una cosa incredibile,
perché - il secondo episodio
che vi voglio raccontare,
che è veramente straordinario,
mi è capitato due anni fa, nel 2016,
perché ho frequentato un corso
organizzato dal MIT.
Da quale argomento?
Dall'ascolto! Incredibile!
Solo che ci ha dato un messaggio diverso,
non ci ha fatto fare questo gioco,
che avete provato,
ma ci ha detto delle cose di testa.
Interessanti.
Quanti tipi di ascolto possiamo fare?
Ce ne ha elencati quattro,
che vi racconto brevemente:
due sicuramente li conoscete,
uno addirittura lo usate tutti i giorni
e ve lo dico in inglese:
"download", scarico di un'immagine,
di un file, di una fotografia.
Lo fate andando in internet,
quindi scaricate qualcosa
e poi magari lo vedete il giorno dopo,
il pomeriggio, dopo un po'.
Questo è il primo ascolto.
Il secondo ascolto è già più impegnativo,
però sicuramente lo fate:
si chiama "ascolto fattuale",
cioè cercate di estrarre, dalle cose
che vi vengono raccontate, i fatti.
Cosa vuol dire? Numeri, dati -
cose concrete, pratiche.
Il terzo tipo di ascolto
è il più impegnativo,
anche se la natura umana, la vostra mente
è predisposta a farlo,
però non è così frequente.
È "l'ascolto empatico".
Vuol dire che vi mettete
nei panni di un'altra persona
e sentite che cosa sente lui:
le emozioni, le paure,
le ansie, il piacere:
vestite i suoi panni,
quindi, i suoi vestiti.
Infine l'ultimo ascolto,
molto più impegnativo
ma molto interessante,
che sicuramente fate
ma potreste migliorare,
si chiama "ascolto generativo".
Vuol dire che man mano
che ascoltate l'altra persona
fate funzionare la vostra mente -
possibilmente liberata,
magari con la tecnica del palloncino, -
per generare immagini, per esempio,
o delle cose più complicate: metafore.
Oppure una cosa
che io trovo difficilissima,
ma magari a qualcuno riesce:
la postura, la gestualità,
cioè la risposta non verbale.
Quindi queste tre cose possono essere
una risposta generativa,
che aiuta l'altra persona
perché gli date una prospettiva diversa.
Quindi vedete che l'ascolto
può far parte della nostra vita
quotidiana, della nostra esperienza
e quindi, sostanzialmente,
è una cosa molto importante.
Bene: adesso, come nei film,
cambiamo scena.
E la scena si rifà
al titolo del nostro incontro,
cioè: "ogni problema ha una soluzione"
Quindi: problema, soluzione!
L'episodio che vi voglio raccontare
per me personalmente avviene nel 2005.
Io, all'epoca - io faccio l'imprenditore.
Ho una società che aiuta
le aziende a fare innovazione.
E lavoravo per una grande azienda
del food, del cibo, dell'alimentare,
e per un anno ho lavorato
per cercare, in giro per il mondo,
le cose più interessanti,
chi ha detto le cose
più interessanti sull'innovazione.
E abbiamo scoperto che nell'anno 2000,
qualche anno prima,
una grande azienda,
che sicuramente conoscete
attraverso i suoi prodotti,
l'azienda americana Procter & Gamble,
nell'anno 2000, con 30 miliardi
di dollari di fatturato, [quindi] enorme,
la Procter and Gamble è in crisi.
Non fa più profitti,
rischia veramente grosso.
Arriva un nuovo presidente,
si chiama Lafley.
Questo signore qui
convoca tutto il suo staff
e gli dà una notizia, cioè dice:
"Io voglio cambiare Procter & Gamble,
ho una strategia in mente.
E la mia strategia è la seguente:
voglio usare, utilizzare
i talenti, le tecnologie
che oggi noi non conosciamo,
non frequentiamo.
Quindi voglio che in cinque anni,
in un periodo di cinque anni,
metà dei prodotti della Procter & Gamble
nascano grazie a un intervento,
una collaborazione esterna".
Per capire la "violenza",
uso questo termine, del messaggio,
dovete sapere quanti ricercatori
aveva Procter & Gamble nell'anno 2000:
8000 persone!
Era una delle aziende
che aveva la più grande concentrazione
di ricerca e sviluppo del mondo.
Lui ci riesce, riesce a fare
questa cosa - come?
Be', non solo attraverso la sua idea,
ma [anche] attraverso
alcune persone della Procter:
dei broker, cioè delle aziende
che nel frattempo si erano formate
per mettere in contatto
i problemi della Procter con i solutori.
Ecco una domanda che mi potreste fare
e che mi ha incuriosito molto,
e a cui sono riuscito
a dare risposta solo da pochi anni:
ma quante persone, nel mondo,
hanno realmente know-how,
conoscenze utili per risolvere i problemi?
Un milione? Dieci milioni?
Voi sapete che oggi siamo,
l'ha detto un oratore poco fa,
7,6 miliardi di persone.
I calcoli più recenti che ho visto -
poi magari sono sbagliati,
non credeteci troppo -
dicono che ci sono 70 milioni di persone
con un know-how tecnologico
o di business rilevante, che può servire.
Sembra ragionevole, no?
Bene, quindi che cosa vuol dire questo?
Che problema e soluzione
sono assolutamente coinvolgenti.
Una cosa interessante è questa:
quando Lafley, nell'anno 2000,
inventa questa strategia,
questa strategia non ha un nome.
È un'idea.
Solo tre anni dopo,
un professore americano
che si chiama Henry Chesbrough,
della Università di Berkley,
quindi un'università importante,
scrive un libro.
Voi sapete che gli americani
sono intelligenti ma anche scaltri, no?
Quindi scrivono i libri con degli scopi.
Lui inventa una parola,
quindi chiama questo sistema di Lafley
"open Innovation".
Tradotto in italiano, "innovazione aperta"
E da quel momento in avanti,
esplode questa sua idea,
si sviluppa in tutto il mondo.
E oggi, se voi aprite
un qualunque sito web,
e scrivete "innovazione aperta",
o "open innovation",
trovate 100.000 risposte.
Gli italiani hanno accolto
con grande fantasia
e grande capacità questo messaggio.
Quindi l'innovazione aperta per me
è stata una svolta anche di imprenditore,
cioè ho cominciato a lavorare
con le imprese su questo.
Quindi, questo è sostanzialmente
quello che vi volevo dire.
Forse voi potreste avere
un’obiezione, ve l'anticipo.
C'è qualcuno di voi che potrebbe dirmi:
"Sì, ma connettere problema a soluzione,
be', ne parlavano gli antichi Greci:
Socrate, Aristotele, gli atomisti -
collegare queste due cose.
Cos’è cambiato?
Quello che è cambiato è che, oggi,
Open Innovation la facciamo tutti,
cioè tutti in questa stanza la fanno.
Vi porto un esempio:
non vi chiedo quanti usano Internet,
perché ci sono sei miliardi
di utenti, nel mondo,
quindi direi che il 99 percento
di voi usa Internet.
Quando voi avete
un problema, una curiosità,
chi è che non è mai andato su Wikipedia?
Chi non ha mai digitato e scritto,
magari come sfida,
il proprio problema in linguaggio naturale
e vi vengono fuori, magari,
un milione di risposte.
Ma nella prima pagina
o nelle prime tre pagine,
credo che sia un'abitudine che avete,
trovate delle cose interessanti.
Quindi, l'innovazione aperta
significa mente aperta, sostanzialmente:
quindi un'abitudine che abbiamo,
ma che è caratteristica
di questo periodo storico,
che è molto importante.
Bene, le due storie sono queste.
Ho ancora qualche secondo
per sciogliere la promessa iniziale,
Ma come sono connesse, queste cose?
Quindi, un problema è qualche cosa
che vi spinge a un'azione:
come potete risolverla?
Qui vedete nella slide
una soluzione tradizionale,
che viene chiamata "innovazione chiusa",
forse un po' cattiva come espressione.
L'innovazione tradizionale
è quella in cui voi rispondete
oppure risponde
la vostra cerchia più vicina
di consulenti - o di fornitori,
se siete un'azienda.
L'altra alternativa è quella
che vi ho spiegato prima,
raccontandovi la storia
di Procter & Gamble.
Ho scritto "crowd" per dire folla:
cioè usiamo il mondo.
Questo è, onestamente,
quello che facciamo oggi,
da adesso in avanti:
ci facciamo aiutare,
ci facciamo supportare
da tanta altra gente.
E allora, l'ascolto a cosa serve?
Per capire l'ascolto,
vi cito una frase
che probabilmente conoscete già,
che fin da piccoli molto spesso ci dicono:
"Un problema ben definito
è metà dell'opera",
cioè se definiamo bene un problema
siamo a metà dell'opera.
Quindi cosa vuol dire?
Vuol dire che, per risolvere un problema,
dobbiamo dedicare molta attenzione
a definire il problema.
Spesso inseguiamo problemi inesistenti,
problemi modesti,
problemi non determinati;
e quindi, la prima cosa
che dobbiamo fare è ascoltarci.
Però attenzione che -
questo è quello che io ho imparato
e che vorrei trasferirvi -
è importante ascoltarci,
ma anche ascoltare gli altri.
Quindi l'ascolto deve essere applicato,
soprattutto in prima battuta,
sul problema.
Questa è praticamente
la risposta che vi dovevo,
e sono contento di avervelo raccontato.
Vi saluto e vi ringrazio.
(Applausi)